reporting 23 people will begin there  folks  have passed away in the last 24 hours  our state saw more than 1400 additional  infections as well that number has been  more than a thousand for  60 of the past 62 days now  11 of those 23 deaths occurred here in  clark county  we're claiming about 1100 of the new  cases as well nearly 157 000 people have  recovered from the virus in clark county  that's 88.8 percent of all reported  cases  the new year is bringing changes to  covet test sites all across  town starting next monday texas station  will operate  three days a week testing there is being  limited next week to 600 people all on a  first come first serve basis  also next monday unlv and cashman center  will start asking for insurance  information  your provider will be billed to start  recouping some of the testing costs but  you still won't have to pay anything out  of pocket  we've got more information about covid  test sites on our website  8newsnow.com